their most famous person in their
contact oh god well now you're working
well now he's the Gladiator now
everybody's in his contact yeah try to
get them out there's the
problem famous person in your
contact you the Gladiator you are no no
no no no phe wer Bridge she's pretty
famous pretty famous you have you can
have that going I can give a little tick
who do you think is the most famous
person in my context Denzel no I don't
have Denzel my contact I'd love to have
Denzel if you're watching this
give us a little
WhatsApp could you imagine there
was shut up talking about a few minutes
later Pedro Pascal yeah yeah yeah you
got that good